[Musique]
leroy clottey revient à noyon recevoir
une dernière bénédiction de saint médard
saint médard c'est le nom de l'église du
village d'elancourt l'édifice est dédié
à cet évêque du moyen-âge saint médard
qui à l'époque donc qui était mis en 456
et bien et est entre autres le créateur
d'une tradition dite de la rose rose qui
mettait en avant les femmes vertueuses
de l'époque on trouve d'ailleurs dans le
vitrail qui est derrière moi vous verrez
une frise entièrement composée de roses
des motifs floraux sur les vitraux et
sur la clé de voûte des peintures de la
croix pattée de type celtique symbole de
la commanderie de lavilledieu une preuve
de remerciement pour l'aide apportée
lors de la construction la construction
a été commencée au 10ème siècle pour se
terminer au 12e siècle là une
particularité c'est que la construction
du 10ème siècle viennent s'était bien
démarré au début était en forme 18 sud
ce qui fait qu arriver à la fin du xième
siècle elle était dans un état qui ne
permettait pas que les 80 paroissiens
les 80 élan courtois de l'époque puisse
à fréquenter et c'est donc sous
l'impulsion des chevaliers du temple que
l'église a été terminé au 12e siècle
pour arriver au bâtiment tel que nous
l'a vu aujourd'hui
huit cents ans d'histoire sauvegardés
par la ville en 1985 elle a rénové les
murs et landry c'est la voûte en bois de
la nef aujourd'hui l'église conserve sa
fonction non lieu de culte des concerts
ils sont également programmés